the one this manga just showed us the
amazing true powers of the pawpaw fruit
it might be the strongest devil fruit in
the story and it could even give its
user the ability to copy other devil
from Powers after eating it the user can
repel anything they touch not only that
but it's one of the few devil fruits
that changes the user's appearance
permanently they get pause on the palms
of their hands which then help them
repel anything that they come in contact
with and I mean anything we've seen it
used for some incredible things it can
be used to teleport people protect from
powerful attacks and in maybe the most
famous scene of One Piece it is used to
expel all of Luffy's pain from his body
which Zorro then takes on in his stats
and now Ichiro order the author of One
Piece has finally fully explained how
its powers truly work because instead of
just being able to repel any physical
object like a sword or a person the papa
fruit additionally also has the special
ability to repel intangible objects as
well like it did with Luffy's paint
pretty cool right that means that you
can also use this fruit to expel all
kinds of things it can remove memories
feelings and thoughts from someone's
body and then turn it into something you
can actually interact with and this is
usually in the form of this big bubble
that looks like a pop for example Zorro
stepped into this one containing Luffy's
pain and in this new manga chapter there
is a sphere containing someone's entire
memories so this fruit is so powerful
you can repel anyone no matter how
strong they are and travel incredibly
fast to wherever you want it can also
push out someone's emotions or pain and
then use it on someone else or simply
store it somewhere but the best part is
that this fruit can do even more than
what we know so far because in this
chapter we find out that Bartholomew
Kuma who ate the papa fruit was not only
begapong's test subject for the Posse
Fist and the seraphim super Advanced
clone soldiers develop for the world
governments but vegapunk used Kuma smash
devil fruit abilities to do all sorts of
other experiments too and being able to
take something invisible like
imagination and turn it into a real
thing so
it's a lot like vegapunk's theory about
how devil fruits are made in the first
place supposedly devil fruits are
created out of people's imagination so
it's possible that vegapunk may have
used Kuma's devil fruit power for his
experiments with devil fruits and the
best evidence for this are actually this
elephant this raccoon and this dog
because none of them are real animals
but objects that have eaten a devil
fruit a sword that ate an elephant devil
fruit a teapot that ate a raccoon fruit
and a cannon that can become a dog we do
know that this new technology was
created by vegapunk but how can an
object eat a devil fruit well according
to this new explanation of Kuma's devil
fruit abilities it should be possible to
push out the intangible power of a devil
fruit and then put it into a new object
so you take the elephant fruit have kuna
extract the power inside and place a
sword inside the sphere so you can take
the elephant fruit have Kuma take out
the power inside which would look like
any of his paw shaped spheres and then
put the sword inside the sphere and so
basically just how Zorro could absorb
Luffy's pain the sword would then absorb
the devil fruit power and if this is
true then there is no argument
whatsoever that the pop-off fruit is the
best devil fruit in one piece but on top
of all this we didn't only learn a lot
about this devil fruit in chapter 1072
we also learned a lot of new things
about its user now in case you don't
know for whatever reason Bartholomew
humor is not only the person who ate the
papa fruit but he's also been one of the
most mysterious and influential
characters in the entire story for Luffy
and the straw hats he has gone full
circle from one of the most terrifying
enemies of the strawheads ever to one of
their biggest allies and protectors so
here's a quick recap the straw hats
first met Kuma in chapter 483 after they
just barely beat the ancient giant oars
who had been transformed into a zombie
by gekkomoria one of the seven Warlords
of the sea who work for the world
governments Luffy was still knocked out
from the fight and the straw hats were
all tired from the battle when Kuma
suddenly showed up on the islands it
turned out that he was another warlord
of the sea who had been instructed by
the government to kill anyone who saw
morya's defeat and in order to protect
Luffy Zoro and Sanji offered themselves
a sacrifice this led to one of my
favorite scenes in all of One Piece
where Zorro took on all of Luffy's pain
in exchange for his freedom and in this
exchange we also found out that Kuma was
actually a person who was turned into a
cyborg by Dr vegapunk which was a great
hint to what would happen on Eckhart
Island and vegapunk telling us all these
things about Kuma in chapter 1072 and
only a short time after their first
encounter the straw hats run into Kuma
again during the Saba ODI archipelago
Arc after punching one of the celestial
dragons the highest crime a person can
possibly commit in the one piece World
Kuma arrives together with Admiral
kizaru and centomaru again mirroring the
current events in the story and while
kizaru is being kept busy by Rayleigh
the straw hats are absolutely decimated
by Kuma as Luffy he has to witness every
last one of his crewmates vanish before
his eyes and at this point in the story
it really seems like Kuma is the worst
enemy The Crew has ever had to face
however after the major loss at Saba ODI
the truth about Kuma slowly came to
light because it turned out that Kuma
was actually trying to protect the
strawhead pirates from Admiral kizaru by
sending each of them to the ideal
location to improve their abilities
during the time skip he had actually
lost much of his free will when he had
become a cyborg weapon for the world
government and that's why he had
attacked his straw hats on Thriller bar
yet he still retained enough of his
Humanity to save them and later even
protect their ship the Thousand Sunny
while it lay unguarded in a Saba ODI
Harbor during the time skip now Kumar
wanted to help the straw hats because he
was one of the three founders of the
Revolutionary Army led by Luffy's father
dragon and because Kuma and dragon are
also friends with Vega Punk Kuma led the
scientists experiment on him and turn
him into a weapon for the government
although we still don't quite understand
why this is the case in the first place
however with his daughter Bonnie about
to step into his bubble of memories it
seems very likely that we will be
getting a tragic Kuma flashback in the
next few chapters that will answer a lot
of our questions here actually make sure
to subscribe to the channel if you don't
want to miss the breakdown of that now
before he became a cyborg or joined the
Revolutionary Army Kuma was actually the
king of a country in fact jimbei tells
us that Kuma got his title of the Tyrant
for being a quite cruel ruler however on
the other hand according to his daughter
Bonnie that is simply not true and
honestly everything we've seen of Kuma
including his flashback with mega punk
in this chapter makes it look like Kuma
was actually a really good person with a
super tragic past and we do know that it
is tragic because vegapunk tells Bonnie
that he promised Kuma not to tell her
the truth about why he became a cyborg
because it would be too painful for her
to hear so whatever the reason is it
sounds like we should prepare a big box
of tissues once we see what really
happened to him one thing we do know for
a fact however is that Kuma is part of a
special race and while it hasn't been
confirmed yet officially it is very
likely that Kuma is a member of the
almost extinct lunarian race so far the
only other known member of this race is
King the right-hand man of kaido who
just like Kuma was heavily experimented
on by the governments the lunarians were
a race of winged humans that lived on
top of the red line before the world
government was established who were
known as the gods they have dark skin
and are able to generate fire from
throughout their bodies and there are a
few pieces of evidence that Kuma is a
lunarium for one he has the same dark
skin as king he was used as the
Prototype for the seraphim soldiers who
all have lunarian wings fire and skin
Luna means moon in Latin hinting at the
fact that the lunarians were the
advanced civilization that lived on the
moon that we saw in a cover story with
NL and if Kuma was a lunarian it would
also explain why Kuma hated the world
government so much and why he formed the
Revolutionary army with dragon just how
King joined forces with the dragon kaido
in addition to that just like other
Warlords Kuma has a strong Animal theme
going on because Kuma in Japanese
literally means bear and as one really
smart Reddit user noticed the Asian
black bear in Japanese is called skino
waguma which literally translates to
ring of the moon bear fun fact
apparently this is also the inspiration
for the Pokemon teddy Orsa which has a
crescent moon usaring which has a new
moon and ursuluna which has a full moon
on its heads the big question is only if
Kuma is a lunarian where are his wings
though it's very possible that he simply
cut them off now meanwhile as vegapunk
is arguing with Bonnie about Kuma we
actually see the real Kuma in chapter
1072 who has teleported himself to the
foot of the red line trying to climb to
the top he's shot down by the Marine
soldiers but he seems determined to
reach his goal whatever that might be so
hopefully we will be getting a whole
flashback for Kuma soon but there is
obviously another major reveal in this
chapter that we still have to talk about
because Stussy of the cp0 agency has
just betrayed Luchi and Kaku and it is
revealed that she is a clone of a former
Rock's crew member the very first
successful clone made by vegapunk's team
of crazy scientists and on top of that
Dusty seems to have what looks like a
vampire Zone devil fruit that just looks
absolutely stunning and of course all of
this has opened up even more questions
that we need answers to now for example
is Stussy the secret female member of
vegapunk's mad science group that we saw
in the cover story of the other chapter
or was it maybe the original Stussy that
got Ben clones we do know for a fact
that as the clone of a rocks pirate
Stussy must be incredibly strong but
then again if she was part of Mads why
didn't sanji's father recognize her
during the wedding ceremony because they
were sitting at the exact same table the
next question is if Stussy is the
mysterious person that vegapunk
contacted to help them because she sure
did help by knocking out Kaku but then
again there could still be someone else
waiting on eckhead Islands also if
Stussy is a perfect clone that actually
begs the question who else in the story
could be a clone as well anyone could be
really I mean maybe Luffy is a clone too
who knows with Oda really and then we
also have to ask where is that original
Stussy of the Rocks Pirates now seems
like the correct answer seems to be this
stunningly beautiful lady here the
mother of Edward Vivo that's because her
name is Bucking while Stussy is
introduced as the clone of Miss
Buckingham Stussy so the names do seem
to match also bucking claims that her
son is the biological son of Whitebeard
which would make sense if they had been
in the same pirate crew and while she
really doesn't look it now if she looked
the same way as Dusty does now in her
youth I could absolutely see Whitebeard
going for her and in any case Weevil is
a very interesting case he could be a
clone as well after all he has those
Stitch marks that Frankie has too or he
could be whitebeard's actual son what's
interesting is that during his
introduction kizaru himself comments
that he definitely has this same power
as a young whitebeards so for now we
have two versions of a rock's crew
member one seems to be on vegapunk's
side for now at least who made her in
the first place while the original seems
to be working with the governments I
really love how this entire situation
suddenly got super intriguing and
there's actually one more thing that I
want to talk about with Stussy that one
of the awesome members of my subreddit
brought to my attention because have you
ever realized that Stussy looks very
very similar to sanji's Mother same eyes
same here but shorter same lips I mean
Stussy was cloned by The Mad Science
group and sanji's Father Judge as you
know was a member of that so could judge
have made another version of Stussy for
himself to create his perfect kid
soldiers with the DNA of a former rocks
member it is also really interesting
that Queen hates judge so much which he
reveals to Sanji during their fight on
wano after all the two of them were
crewmates and we also know that Queen
deals really poorly with with being
rejected by women it happens with both
hiori and one of the geishas during the
fight with Sanji who has to save her
life so could it be that Queen hates
judge for having married a version of
Stussy a woman that he fell in love with
during that time together as part of
their crew as I've said more questions
than answers so instead let's talk about
GARP setting out to fight Blackbeard if
you haven't heard my thoughts on the
crazy last chapter then make sure to
check out that discussion right here
thanks for watching